please welcome california senator kamala
harris
and vice president mike pence
the american people have witnessed what
is
the greatest failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country
and our plan is about what we need to do
around a national strategy
for contact tracing for testing for
administration of
the vaccine and making sure that it will
be free for all
and quite frankly when i look at their
plan that talks about
advancing testing creating new ppe
developing a vaccine
um it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
and i think the american people know
that would you like to respond
absolutely
whatever the vice president is claiming
the administration has done
clearly it hasn't worked when you're
looking at over 210
000 dead bodies in our country american
lives
that have been lost families that are
grieving that loss
dr anthony fauci and other experts say
that most of the people who can be
vaccinated
need to be vaccinated but half of
americans now say they wouldn't take a
vaccine
if it was released now if the trump
administration approves a vaccine
before or after the election should
americans
take it and would you take it if the
public health professionals if dr fauci
if
the doctors tell us that we should take
it i'll be the first in line to take it
absolutely but if donald trump tells us
i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i i just
ask you
stop playing politics with people's
lives the reality
is that we will have a vaccine we
believe before the end of this year
and it will have the capacity to save
countless
american lives and and your continuous
undermining
of confidence in a vaccine is just it
it's just
unacceptable the day i got the call from
from joe biden it was
actually a zoom call asking me to
serve with him on this ticket was
probably one of the most memorable
memorable days of my life and i also
want to congratulate you
uh as i did on that phone call on
the historic nature of your nomination
uh
i i never expected to be on this stage
four years ago so
i know the feeling let's look at taxes
um we now know because of
great investigative journalism that
donald trump paid
750 dollars in taxes
and it'd be really good to know who the
president of the united states the
commander-in-chief
owes money to because the american
people have a right to know
what is influencing the president's
decisions
and is he making those decisions on the
best interest of the american people of
you
or self-interest the american people
have a president
who's a businessman it's a job creator
who's paid tens of millions of dollars
in taxes
payroll taxes property taxes he's
created tens of
thousands of american jobs and the
president said those
public reports are not accurate and the
president's also released
literally stacks of financial
disclosures the american people can
review just as the law allows joe biden
said twice in the debate last week that
he's going to repeal the trump tax cuts
that was tax cuts that gave the average
working family
two thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year
senator that is absolutely not true that
is he only cutting
is he only going to repeal part of the
trump tax cuts if you don't mind letting
me finish
we can then have a conversation okay
please okay
joe biden will not raise taxes on anyone
who makes less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year he has been very
clear about that
joe biden will not end fracking he has
been very clear about that
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer they're coming
for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you thank
you
coming for you if you are under the age
of 26 on your
parents coverage they're coming for you
you know what's remarkable
is the united states has reduced co2
more than the countries that are still
in the paris climate accord but we've
done it through innovation
and we've done it through natural gas
and fracking
the west coast of our country is burning
including my home state of california
joe sees what is happening on the gulf
states
which are being battered by storms and
joe's plan
is about saying we're going to deal with
it but we're also going to create jobs
donald trump when asked about the
wildfires in california
and and the question was you know the
science is telling us this you know what
donald trump said
science doesn't know china is to blame
for the coronavirus
and president trump is not happy about
it he's made that very clear made it
clear again today
china and the world health organization
did not play straight with the american
people
they did not let our personnel into
china
to get information on the coronavirus
until the middle of february
fortunately president trump in dealing
with china from the outset of this
administration
standing up to china that had been
taking advantage of america for decades
in the wake of joe biden's cheerleading
for china
president trump made that decision
before the end of january to suspend
all travel from china it's about
relationships
and the thing that has always been part
of the strength of our nation
in addition to our great military has
been that we keep
our word but donald trump doesn't
understand that because he doesn't
understand
what it means to be honest with regard
to the supreme court of the united
states
let me say president trump and i could
not be more enthusiastic
about the opportunity to see judge amy
coney barrett become justice amy coney
barrett
she's a brilliant woman and she will
bring a lifetime of
experience and a sizable american family
to the supreme court of the united
states
the issues before us couldn't be more
serious there's the issue of choice
and i will always fight for a woman's
right to make a decision about her own
body it should be her decision and not
that of donald trump
and the vice president michael penn i i
couldn't be more proud to serve as vice
president to a president who stands
without apology for the sanctity of
human life
i'm pro-life i i don't apologize for it
and this is another one of those cases
where there's such a dramatic
contrast joe biden and kamala harris
support
taxpayer funding of abortion all the way
up to the moment of birth
late term abortion they want to increase
funding to planned parenthood
of america now for our part i i would
never presume how judge amy coney
barrett
would rule on the supreme court of the
united states but
will continue to stand strong for the
right to life your party is actually
openly advocating adding seats to the
supreme court
which has had nine seats for 150 years
if you don't get your way this is a
classic case of if you can't win by the
rules
you're going to change the rules abraham
lincoln was
up for re-election and it was 27 days
before the election
and a seat became open on the united
states supreme court
abraham lincoln's party was in charge
not only the white house but the senate
but honest abe said
it's not the right thing to do the
american people
deserve to make the decision about who
will be the next president of the united
states
and then that person can select who will
serve for a lifetime
on the highest court of our land senator
harris
in the case of riona taylor was justice
done
you have two minutes i don't believe so
and i've i've talked with
brianna's mother tamika palmer and her
family
and her family deserves justice she was
a beautiful young woman
she had as her life goal to become a
nurse and she wanted to become an emt to
first learn
what's going on out on the street so she
could then
become a nurse and save lives and her
life is taken
unjustifiably and tragically and
violently
well our heart breaks for the loss of
any
any innocent american life and the
family of brianna taylor has our
sympathies
but i trust our justice system
a grand jury that refused the evidence
and it really is remarkable that as a
former prosecutor
you would assume that an empaneled grand
jury looking at all the evidence got it
wrong
but you're entitled to your opinion
senator
i will not sit here and be lectured by
the vice president
on what it means to enforce the laws of
our country i am the only one on this
stage
who has personally prosecuted everything
from child sexual assault to homicide
i'm the only one on the stage who has
prosecuted the big banks
for taking advantage of america's
homeowners i'm the only one on this
stage
who prosecuted for profit colleges for
taking advantage of our veterans
and the reality of this is that we are
talking about an election in 27 days
where last week the president of the
united states took a debate stage in
front of 70 million americans
and refused to condemn white
supremacists
not true he on the issue of
charlottesville
where people were peacefully protesting
the need for racial justice where a
young woman was killed
and on the other side there were
neo-nazis carrying tiki torches
shouting racial epithets
anti-semitic slurs
and donald trump when asked about it
said
there were fine people on both sides
senator harris conveniently admitted
after after the president made comments
about people
on either side of the debate over
monuments
he condemned the kkk neo-nazis and white
supremacists and has done so
repeatedly you're concerned that he
doesn't
condemn neo-nazis president trump has
jewish grandchildren
his daughter and son-in-law are jewish
this is a president who
who respects and cherishes all of the
american people
if your ticket wins and president trump
refuses to accept
a peaceful transfer of power what steps
would you in vice president biden then
take what would happen
so i'll tell you um joe and i are
i think particularly um proud of
the coalition that we've built around
our campaign we probably have one of the
broadest coalitions of folks that you've
ever seen in a presidential race of
course we have the support of democrats
but also
independents and republicans in fact um
seven members of
president george w bush's cabinet are
supporting our ticket
we have the support of of colin powell
cindy mccain john kasich
over 500 generals retired generals and
and former national security experts and
advisors are supporting our campaign
and i believe they are doing that
because they know that joe biden
has a deep deep-seated commitment to
fight for our democracy
senator your party has spent the last
three and a half years trying to
overturn the results of the last
election it's amazing
when joe biden was vice president of the
united states
the fbi actually spied on president
trump and my campaign
i mean there were documents released
this week that the cia actually made a
referral uh
to the fbi documenting that those
allegations were coming from the hillary
clinton campaign and of course
we've all seen the avalanche what what
you put the country through
for for the better part of three years
until it was found that there was no
obstruction no collusion case closed
and then senator harris you and your
colleagues in the
in the congress tried to impeach the
president of the united states
over a phone call